yellow welcome to our monday night live
show one hour or cheese explained at
least I try yeah I'm trying to explain
some of my thoughts and chaotic ideas in
the five-minute pool on the ICC you're
welcome also to all of you in the chat
it's not yet that busy we'll see what
happens there okay i'm going to do 45
minute games of course like i usually do
i did not have a good run i have to say
lost quite a bit of points and maybe I'm
getting something back but spoon I
didn't you all that well and have
requested the game not yet paired are
there a couple of a couple of high rated
guys yard was not to 560 which is crazy
high ok Zalman see is that not quite
sure there's a name in that anyway ok we
have an English opening which I continue
to do well in terms of positions I mean
I get good positions but I should try to
score more points it's the thing ok just
D sexy in this position um how do I do
this with d3 or I could also go III here
let's do a three hello and please when
yeah I try thanks for the good wishes
yeah yeah thanks John I had a game
versus Peter Svidler and one of them
shows that he does for chess to any
phone and no yeah I lost this game but I
put up a pretty decent defensive effort
out of a rotten position I spoiled a
very good opening position against him
and what I got was a really really bad
bank or gambit it was really awful but
then I just defended quite well and it
was really it was really a okay for me
um still tricky but it was an ok
position anyway so zama and see what do
we do here um yeah h3 is under attack
what to do what to do cannot Castle
night f4 is possible I can also go a
form that is actually quite a decent
idea let's do that it closes the
diagonal but I have very good center now
his pieces don't make all that much
sense in fighting against the board
winning set up okay maybe 90 80 70 60
can still go 98 no e6 he goes okay yeah
I can Cass all right
okay let's develop do I have any opinion
on slot and you mean slot on Ibrahimovic
I guess yeah is it possible to not not
have an opinion on slot on is it
possible probably not yeah I mean you're
Ceaser of course a total nutcase but
it's one of those cases where um well
yeah the the people who really do
extraordinary things they sometimes are
not cases and this is certainly the case
with mr. Ibrahimovic I mean is really
completely completely crazy but what it
does is of course at times hard to
believe so it's i'm a fan in terms of
football not so much about what he tends
to ya tend to say in interviews and so
on it's always somewhat entertaining i
mean it is it is it is it's i mean i
think it's cool that people actually are
not the data that there are so people
around in football that that actually
are opinionated and I able to say
something that is not totally boring
which is the typical footballer
interview nowadays I think they are
there many people footballers
management's they they sent the players
to some courses so that they don't make
a total fool out of themselves in front
of the microphone I kind of understand
that but it's also terribly boring and
so I think it's pretty cool if someone
is is making some yeah some politically
incorrect jokes or whatever yet
something that you usually don't just
don't say and he's not afraid of doing
it okay so um yeah this is what I
expected I wasn't quite sure how to
capture
this is maybe an idea and to simply to
strengthen the center controlled e4 yes
Latin as a couple of cool quotes yeah oh
i blundered this pawn I didn't think
about this move arrow
I can still put some pressure on the be
porn hmm now maybe 95 that don't like it
of course I just blundered Quincy form
the funky move yeah he might structure
is worse and he's got the bishop habit I
have a pretty decent night yeah to put
39g to get out of those under the
situation okay I wonder if trading and
this is a debatable I know but I know
intertek b7 yeah it was bad i mean i had
a really good position I was a pawn up
for nothing much interesting move
baby bishops is sixsome I saw that a bit
late I here actually thought Knight b6
could be okay
and it isn't good it really isn't
you
check hi morning as I'm running into
right into f5 which I didn't see
beforehand and Bishop deform
appreciative for King at four maybe I
can sulfide it doesn't look good down
and really doesn't there are some
chances here with the wrong bishop I
could have taken a five why didn't they
take a five yeah I'm sure about it I
don't get I don't get it that this I
don't get this pawn I think
I it's it's still lost so lost cannot do
it cannot defend this okay so i actually
get the draw it was lucky very long very
lucky drawn and you one of the pot the
petrol visit a decent opening for the
average club player gr of course here
you can play it it it sounds it's a
sound opening um and I don't think it is
start all of that boring if you you ask
me some lines are not very interesting
but that happens with many openings a
good advantage of the Petrov is that it
is not so well known on the club level
it's pretty much almost never played and
this is certainly an advantage for the
black player okay this is um what's the
precise name yakov fun glute yeah he's a
grandmaster from from Denmark I believe
I'm going with my wood line yeah I do
the at least once against every strong
play and see how they handle this stodgy
position can you play the arch Arch
Angel line I don't really know it so I'm
a little bit skeptical if I should play
it
what's my favorite fruit and yeah I like
Mediterranean fruit Greek Italian things
like that I don't like a typical German
food all that much yeah there are some
things that you typically associate with
this Germany like I don't know
sauerkraut and like usually rather had
meat and I don't really like stuff like
that but i also like its think some like
him let's say some asian stuff oh I also
like Egyptian or things like that it
sounds very interesting it's not so well
um yeah I'm not so well known or not as
usual at same but this kind of food is
quite interesting to take to dry so I
think I'll go see for here not totally
sure about this but yeah I kind of
expected this expected this to happen I
wanted to want to put the bishop over to
be 6
not sure if it is doing all that much to
be honest knight on d4 is not not bad
but ok it doesn't really look like
doesn't really look like he has a
brilliant idea here or I don't
understand it of course it's very much
possible I can just drop back no then
have six drops hmm I can't take and put
something on d6 but I don't see and now
night of seven is actually interesting
because he has to take more or less no
it's giving me this huh ok after he's
got a five maybe four Bishop g6 so it's
not clear that I want to take on this on
this but i think i will still take yeah
yeah this design is really it's it's
it's probably like some kind of
addiction yeah you know it's not good
for you it you somehow don't give a give
up on it I really should do that i mean
i have i've given up on the line for
tournament chess I mean definitely I've
never I will never play it again and
tournament play after freeze on my blog
totally killed me check and but but in
in blitz I still check I mean it has
some value in blitz it really has
because you you can play many moves
quite quickly if you know the ideas and
isn't that kind of okay for me now looks
kind of okay
night f4 and that ur 436 but I can i can
actually take on d4 and take you for ya
egyptian food yeah that that's pretty
good good stuff but you don't get it all
that often in Germany you don't often
see Egyptian restaurants it's still on
so rather uncommon so night over to e5
just focus on your form you five Bishop
g4 okay what's I would you recommend
against way for 1,900 to 2000 USCF
player and this is a lot depending on
your star I like him the early
deviations actually on move three and
move forward because most of these lines
are totally valid and and it's often a
good surprise for a white the shriman or
enh gambit for example is interesting to
play or 3g 6 or 397 those lines are all
completely okay and they are not as well
um people don't know it don't know them
so well I can actually take on Jack
their wealth oh my goodness what's the
heck I didn't expect that moves ahead or
not at all he's got night f5
King here what's going on here I don't
don't get it you can also go here Bishop
g6 maybe just look at and then you might
okay okay come on play it simple it take
you for check it's a full exchange white
resigns that's a question how many chess
related books I've written I just one
just one only written one game started
one book I've produced some other stuff
though video serious and stuff like that
kill ya displaying the Italian he always
does and I'm struggling yes it's true
that i mentioned that I'm supportive
chesa ball that's true i'm um i'm i'm
working on repertoires for that site
currently on the bank or repertoire i
use the site yeah not for learning
myself a userform creating repertoire
stew to offer to people of course I've
used it myself to do to talk to
understand how it how it works and stuff
but I'm not learning any opening
currently on the side even though it
said it's a good tool okay
Queen to f3 and that's just creepy 7 yes
this funky line where white is castling
playing age 3 which i think is rubbish
but it is still you have to refute it
and I often managed but not as often as
I should yeah that's a good one there's
a yeah a chat a message in the in the
chat that the Italian is the white
players revenge for the petrol of and
the Berlin yeah this is probably in some
way true where it's at least a very
funny statement the Italian game is so a
time so boring that you can know fell
asleep but maybe this is the proper
revenge but I don't even play them I
don't even play the villain or the
petrol so I feel like they punish me for
something that yeah I shouldn't deserve
to be punished for okay ahead we should
be two already but I wanted to cancel
cannot be a bad idea rook g5 for Luke h5
isn't that strong let's check it out
looks very strong actually now white
white here now is I think it's getting
his proper punishment for that line I
really think it's rubbish to castle
until age three if black has not
cancelled yet Luke age five looks pretty
awful
okay let's see is that still some kind
of defense for him here this is this is
a move yes but I can take and take an f
21 I could double now let's take them
let's take them and now i can take f 2
which is a pawn let's start with taking
this pawn shouldn't be all that bad yeah
Bishop to g3 he's got this check though
but still I think the bishop is good
there check can you play the hippo
against any opening and almost yeah I
think it's tough to prevent entirely
okay so Knight to c4 is attacking my
rook hmm yes I wonder about this move
nighty 32 f five looks a little bit
annoying here they definitely don't want
him to take my rogue here
night we three will be helpful for him
anyway but I can go 27 and 97 probably
trading lad okay so and I go back and
now i need i can do this you can maybe
take age 6
Quinn to e6 Maria hmm still not still
struggling here in this game it's not
not so easy really do and it was a
question how good am I draw its I that's
funky I don't even know the rules I mean
I'd not even the robots have basically
no idea about the game I know it's
played on on a chessboard yes but but I
don't even know how it works have no
idea okay so i traded this 95 as a
potential idea currently g-twang so i
think it probably will provoke g1 or
something like that i could take a two
and i think i'm probably going to do
that i would like to trade the night but
97 vote even threatened to take it
because of that that fork yahoo group g1
that's what I expect but maybe mmm maybe
he cannot do that I have worked for
maybe I wonder ever have a move like
rookie for just keeping this pawn or
maybe maybe the night looks extremely
shaky and whites position I would like
to play the smooth but not sure
might even take you may not even take h6
it could work my 97 is also something
okay come on I take stuff now so what's
going on here take on g2 rook takes
Queen c1 check and pick up f4
it should maybe seal the deal tyranny
check containing hook h4 awkward which
for does not win the Queen so but let's
just run the a porn he has a huge
problem here moving his pieces all right
it's difficult to ya night you for that
was night age six maybe I didn't really
try to figure that out this is seem to
not simple on okay so I should probably
just take I don't have a check check
okay I can I can keep this stuff don't
have to sacrifice check
check check check okay I get a new queen
like Rosanna okay that was good happy
with this is a super tough opponent I've
got now 42 games against tomorrow plus
to score and very little draw very few
drawers it's always good he's a good
player okay um some kind of a message
that I care nothing gained nerdy ok back
to back yeah there was a request that I
play something else in the English I
totally understand your point but I like
to play specifically this against him I
wouldn't I would have done something
else against some other guy but I have a
particular idea here that's a strange
setup wow wow time to believe in that so
we should be three egos d4
and I can just take right d for I can
take d 4 94 94 Queenie for check and
that already is a big issue for black
yeah I can take right what why is that
not working Knight takes Knight takes
Queen a 496 wind speed shop c 6 wins
stuff 96 doesn't work you I can take
Jack should win a big big Center pond
yeah so 96 I can take a seven as well
yeah that looks pretty bad so maybe I
can actually win some points in the
session which is not easy to do
now it's taking along think I may be
time for me to get some water ok men
question is learning how to take Queen
takes or Bishop takes Bishop takes beef
no be five will be five hmm ok with the
Queen as from a not a huge difference I
mean it's a difference of course but in
terms of quality I mean so what to do
now is success coming you six Bishop c5
I won't ever have something that really
ends the game is actually not coming
because g7 hangs ok so then just let us
develop now I don't have any tournament
plans in in Austria at the moment I'm
going to play a small tournament in
Germany in mid-october of it it's not
it's nothing nothing big it's just a
five-round small Swiss event that i'm
going to attend with some clubmates will
be will be fun can't you drink water
from the tap in Germany as a question um
yeah the German water from the tab is
usually quite ok it's a very well tested
very well tested um beverage but
current where I live we have a little
bit of we have some issues there the
there's lots of are not sure what the
name is in in English some stuff we have
some stuff in the water which is not
necessarily totally unhealthy but it's a
little bit questionable to to drink lots
of it and the other thing is that we
have in meijer in the house where I live
we have relatively old relatively old
pipes and I really I don't really trust
it all that much this this water so i
usually go with Jack mineral water Jeff
going to play the Bundesliga no we my
club on the lab recently yeah we got
them we we got what's up what is what is
the right word for that we got demoted
no that's Oliver right relegated that's
relegated right yeah we got relegated to
the third League so that's technically
not the Bundesliga anymore but it's it's
the highest League of my state which is
so pretty strong okay um Kelly unwise
idea the opening result was just too bad
to to stand gain started the great fair
okay I can do some I can play as a sonia
against the great fair and see what
happens this is probably going to be
shaky me playing the night off
no the pipes that we have they are not
data water there from the original of
the building was built in the late 60s
so how do i normally do in time trouble
over the board because online I
sometimes seem to lose it if I don't get
into time travel in over the board games
at all I'm a very fast player you really
have time left I sometimes get into town
trouble when I really have a rotten
position and I don't seem just don't see
moves that work and then I tend to use
more time but this is I think a very
natural thing to happen but I'm not a
very regular time time travel personal
at all
yeah okay we played this is slow in the
head I went for a night off and my
opponent has gone for the the souls in
fishers I was in variation yeah I did
Rita neither shorts comments about the
cheating check it was kind of funny yeah
I chose the lungs are as my first name
in my channel because um I I pretty much
quickly found out that my play is
somewhat slowish with the commentary and
this is why I felt langsam is
appropriate it doesn't refer to
tournament chess yeah I wonder what
happens if he cancels long okay he
didn't fit
yeah do I take on what I think I'll take
and now
my favorite player of the current
players to learn I really don't have a
clear favorite as I mentioned sometimes
I like aronian because of his really
sometimes creative and dumb and somewhat
unconventional style without being like
yeah without being let's say what do you
call it without being too too um so too
too risky let's say I'm you have you
have people like like report or Joe Baba
to play very creatively but they often
play at times just badly and that
doesn't happen all that much with with
Aronian but I really like him lots of
the top players also like cars in a lot
because mostly in some case was somewhat
non theoretical approach she really
tries to yeah not been in the opening
but try to outplay people in middle and
end games which is really great yeah I
mean short short was clearly chosen
because he has a has a beef with an
arbiter who chose him for that for that
control and I'm not all that surprised
to have to say that he run into problems
with this particular arbiter when he
mentioned he mentioned the name in the
interview and I googled him and I
actually know that person he also was an
arbiter in the European club cup two
years ago and it I have no real um big
story there but I think that that guy
was somewhat irritating very much yeah
enforcing stuff like yeah I'm the
arbiter I have to do this and then
whatever it he felt like em
there are some people who do those are
between jobs that really are not in
there because they want to want to help
the players or anything but they mostly
want to do is they want to exert some
kind of power over people and yeah and
this guy struck me as such a person but
just it was just that what my mind my
feelings when when I was in that my
feelings set the right word when I was
in that tournament so okay I have some
counter play against you form he has the
rukon the g file but i am not seeing
this not currently I'm much afraid of
this attack and I have potentially d5 to
completely open everything up
so he attacks age 6 yeah okay Kingy age
7 is the way to cover it
it's always risky there's always some
risk involved the good thing is that I'm
a little bit ahead of a clock okay what
are you going to do here great fan okay
so i can now win-win a pawn yeah I will
do that okay can also take e for but if
I take this and then just play Bishop f6
that should be fairly safe and see to d5
are still extremely weak I don't think
you will be able to cover the pawns yes
yammer also which is also really really
creative interesting player I don't
think he's playing all that much
nowadays I'm not not quite sure maybe he
plays events like the Russian league or
so would you don't see him much in in in
top events or even though still tops
mrs. i think if i'm not mistaken he's
doing some i think he has some some bud
jobs is to the coach in some way check
in what oh my god did a blunder no i
don't think so in the end of the Gulf
states i'm not quite sure which one
white resign okay so I defended that I'm
always scared in those openings when
they come come after me I'm always
scared this is why i usually don't play
it and have my doubts about this
position really
ok so I'm going for this time tacticals
that's not an opponent that I do well
against minus what is that minus 5 ok so
I pre mostly please go nowadays that's
interesting yeah that's that's supposed
to be a really interesting game chest
you know mine showed me the rules of go
and I thought it's pretty interesting
it's just that I don't I mean there's no
way I'm going to study a second game in
some kind of seriousness and I'm not the
kind of person who just yeah play some
plays a game and is happy with being bad
so I'm not going to go look in to go all
that much but I understood it's an
interesting game I really am I
understood some basic concepts and I
hope and I understand why people think
it's interesting ok so I'm going to
trade this Bishop I think this is almost
invariably an achievement ok so I'm
going to take here this is one point of
having the night on e seven that you can
actually take that that's not night xf6
it's a really important point check ok
so he takes on e seven interesting
I wonder if i take here and then e for
if this is an idea pad I don't know it
doesn't look right it doesn't look right
ok I can take their k take this first
and now see what happens ok I don't
really think d 4 is much of a problem we
play in non-committal move going to be
three men I can just centralized always
be five coming up hmm come on I go
before now i can't just cannot resist to
open it ok so he doesn't mind the trade
here ok so let's trade my bishop 187
looks a tad stupid yeah but ok I can do
this right it's maybe not a bad moment
to do that Bishop c3 or ever that could
be a good move no just do that ok I
interesting
interesting my opening serious about the
Bangkok gambit witches and it is still
in the works but it's almost finished
I'm on eighty percent maybe a little bit
more ninety percent okay
I was thinking 95 should be good but
maybe I'm wrong books by John none they
have an excellent reputation it's kind
of strange actually because i have so
many books about chess and had many
books over the years I've given away
lots of them actually as gifts on
donations for my chess club or stuff
like that and it's really strange I
absolutely don't have any of those John
nine books like yes some endgame books
and so on and somehow I never had any of
them like secrets of paula's endings and
said things like that I I I don't have
them I don't have them so this is really
a gap in mine in my book my knowledge
about chess books but everybody thinks
those nuns books are excellent so oh I
totally forgot that b6 is hanging as
well if it comes to see for shoot that's
totally unnecessary mMmmm I had it it
was suppose a pretty harmless position
actually at the beginning check I
completely forgot that
and I have a staff was terrible I should
never get into trouble from this
completely harmless position now I don't
understand you can just take these 16
okay so yeah the other one that was from
be 97 I see ok so let's take this maybe
I can get enough counter play here
against the point B 5
yeah I don't let her don't really don't
have I think it ever actually no book by
John man I think no book at all which is
really strange he has written lots of
books and I've bought lots of books and
he has done things that definitely in
would interest me but somehow someway I
don't don't have any of them okay this
pawn Knight up I can go all the way
there I can go to c7 and then to e6 and
don't think I should lose this okay look
these six maybe know the NIA text my
rook cannot do that so I have to go here
Ruby five maybe
energy form time warning cannot activate
my look at the moment this is really a
bit of a problem check
and yes
yeah I screwed that up completely
entirely fully whatever look you cannot
go there and it's got knight c6 around
the corner yeah really nothing to do
about it check
check I really I really hate to lose
this game because it was such a harmless
position come on shake I kept it on time
it was such a harmless position you
should never lose this I mean like this
position how can you lose this was black
that's pretty awful okay now I didn't
see that d6 and b6 were hanging
otherwise i can just go for a different
structure I mean like here I can take on
c5 or whatever this is um yeah it's
simply not much going on in this
position anyway okay I'm requesting a
new game so its side almost kicked me
almost below 2400 again gain started
making no sense yeah I said I will play
something else okay so i go your phone
and see what i can do in the open
cesarean okay not not one of the more
common lines yeah this is the blue
mirror which attack right b6 is a
strategic mistake I don't think so I
mean you can
can argue about the move but I don't
think it's it's terribly bad so this is
not exactly my kind of opening so it
will see what what happens here before
yeah where do i go to be one then
probably doesn't look so great but a
four is this very stranded so I'm calf
cavity for covered and g5 is the next
move now I didn't see the movie Tony
admin yeah it's supposed to be really
good yes no I didn't I didn't so d5 and
normally you go if I VN just two sec the
porn so I think I'll do that black can
take the pawn it says no big tricky or
anything he can't take it I go at four
g5 and so on just for tempe I didn't
want to open up the diagonal
yeah I think no big choice he had to
take it can maybe go 94 here right yes
ok so maybe takes I can also take with
the bishop then at five but it's got a
five is the problem yeah anyway I have
to continue to play aggressively him ok
so you text this night now somewhat I
actually he can also casts a long style
this is really irritating yeah I wonder
ever have to cover this so if i can
sacrifice it somehow
ok
what would have been doing for a job is
it if it wasn't shares i mean i did an
on chest job for like 17 18 years and
that was enough yeah but now at least at
least this is a somewhat irritating porn
okay so take here and then see if i can
can play with I can take a firm maybe
that's a crazy idea night if for Bishop
takes you for Bishop f4 wow that's
totally crazy let's do it it probably is
making no sense as the name suggests but
it's definitely a bit of a shocker
maybe you can actually take you for but
I think just struck t4 as possible
that's crazy I mean yeah have no idea of
this objectively words but it's funny he
definitely cannot take yeah I mean now I
can take on e4 and what then does he
castle or what to see do I also might be
five said something probably not if I
take you for I mean he might just cancel
show diem anyway h4 h5 is the is the
thing if he takes here that's a tempo
though that's a little bit awkward so
can I go with the night somewhere how it
feels incorrect right that feels like
it's not correct he can take on d for
the night is the problem
maybe I should have gone I'd f5 actually
something like that I think it should
take on d4 with the pawn so that it's a
temple on money it's a check out this
one ok ok so let's let's go down oh wow
so Bishop know ok let's see Jack Bishop
takes I have g7 led wins for white I
think that was wrong to be honest and he
I n96 kind of an obvious move do we have
some do I have something better here
night is seven also would be check made
night f5 is actually good yeah this is
good threatens 97 threat night age six
and if you takes Queen takes is made on
h7 so this is killing and it's just made
on age 79 if not for this move oh my
goodness
hmm time warning oh my god oh my
goodness rook d7 I don't see a maid
there it's very close of course this may
be for Queen h5 if I take on f7 chat
again I have to have to play okay I
cannot take edge tool can check here
check check yeah that does the trick
check okay black resign so that was
probably not entirely correct this game
but it was fun right that was fun so I
just want to briefly check how the
engine nerves at me at this so it takes
so what what does the engine says okay
the engine wants to play this is simple
move okay so let's just check how crazy
it is so here here so okay the computer
the computer takes age one it's just
merciless it doesn't work at all you can
take you can take here and then he's got
Quincy for so the computer is spoiling
all the fun as usual like here auntie
God's gets Castle long so it was a pure
Bluff Queen takes cancels yeah and now
here yes to take a thought years to take
here and I've helped that this is fairly
clearly winning
it still is a little bit of something
but it shouldn't work and this so came
in here okay now no I mean no I'm okay
again it seems check this oops sorry
about that no I just clean up 3 wins
yeah going over but this just looked
cute right and it does win Queen age 3
win suit okay this that is all chapters
windows check check and this is this is
reject this is checkmate yeah this was
the alternative but check that's also
ending with the maid okay guys are close
to a big sneeze yeah come on what ok
guys thanks for watching I hope you
enjoyed the show it was a fun session I
think gained a couple of points and had
some some funny non-standard games I'll
be back next week of course next Monday
same time and same place youtube for icc
there will also be a show on sunday
evening sunday evening i'm not quite
sure about the time it's probably eight
in the evening central europe in town
where i'm going to play a similar
taneous display against roughly 20 ICC
members will be on Sunday so i'll post
an announcement video for that anyway so
you would get detailed information where
to go to and so on in the next couple of
days hope you enjoyed it till Sunday or
Monday bye bye